tu me réponds je te demande un truc j'en
ai plein le cul des flics de
pardon
renseignement que je te choque dans le
quartier toi tu regardes ta casquette
je te demande à renseignement tu me le
donnes connard sale flics
pas dans le quartier de quoi
on est plus en sécurité
beaucoup beaucoup de vols
des collègues et qu'on vous embarque
dans la gueule pour dégaine si tu as des
couilles tu es qu'une merde filée
que je te croise pas dans le Carême
il a été sympa quand même
tu me réponds
dans le quartier toi tu as intérêt à
planquer tes miches tu crois pas ça des
impôts qu'on paye sur la place
c'est moi la police monsieur
je te demande connard je te pose une
question
il est servi à lui répondre monsieur
connard là
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu